a background is a children's performer
and drawing inspiration from Mr Bean the
person behind are the Clown's heavy
makeup looks completely different out of
costume Pennywise isn't the only circus
performer killing it and the horror
genre these days in fact Pennywise
reputation is the scariest clown in pop
culture is arguably being contested by
another haunting Persona that is
reportedly causing audiences to faint
and vomit in movie theaters for evening
standard the critically acclaimed
terrifier 2 directed by Damien Leone
sees a return of the seriously creepy
art the clown the character first
appeared in Leone's 2013 Anthology flick
All Hallows Eve in which art was played
by Mike Gianelli the first full-length
terrifier film starring David Howard
Thornton as art was Unleashed upon
audiences in 2016. the end result was an
86-minute gore-filled bloodbath of
Terror featuring a nightmare inducing
Menace in the form of art the clown the
low budget feature may not have all the
bells and whistles of most big name
horror 6 but Leone somehow managed to
max out the Mayhem in every frame thanks
in part to well-crafted monster art a
creepy clown killer has received
significant acclaims since his debut
with far-sighted claiming that art makes
Stephen King's Pennywise look more like
Krusty the Clown from The Simpsons
saying that the yags are behind the
iconic makeup deserves a lot of credit
for helping director Leone realize his
goal about doing the first film with the
sequel and after fans watch the ending
of terrifier 2 they may have been
curious to know what art the clown looks
like out of costume actor David Howard
Thornton plays art the clown in both
terrifier and terrifier too Thornton's
career is made up of an assortment of
credits including theater and voice over
work which don't just involve homicidal
clowning around he has appeared in the
DC drama series Gotham and has also done
voice over work for the Hulu animated
series the bravest night but after
perusing his resume it quickly becomes
clear that Thornton's most notorious
claim to fame to date is without a doubt
playing art the clown much of the praise
heaped upon the terrifier films
recognize both the Hideous on-screen
actions of the vile face painter killer
and the actor playing him Starburst
magazine commended the frightful clown
writing art is a truly enigmatic and
memorable villain he frequently veers
into the territory of being genuinely
unpleasant to watch which makes him feel
somewhat separate from the stable of
horror icons such as Freddy Krueger and
Chucky but the character can't take all
of the credit and the publication also
praised swordson's brilliant performance
writing special acknowledgment should be
given to David Howard Thornton for a
truly wonderful performance and one that
easily stands Toe to Toe with the likes
of Curry and Skarsgard it might seem
like playing a terrifying clown murderer
is the farthest thing away from
kid-friendly entertainment but for
Thornton his past work as a performer
for children came in handy Thornton
revealed to dread Central that he scored
the horrifying role by auditioning on
Actors Access with a call out asking for
tall and skinny performers with clowning
or physical comedy experience while
thornson was new to clowning physical
comedy was in his wheelhouse and his
years doing Children's Theater made him
stand out to the casting director
according to Backstage Thornton
previously studied at the fantasy
Playhouse Children's Theater in
Huntsville Alabama which unexpectedly
helped prepare him for the terrifier I
would honestly like to make one more and
have an idea for a solid Trilogy given
that out the clown doesn't have any
lines Thornton's physical comedy
training came in very handy in addition
to his Children's Theater experience he
also Drew inspiration from other great
physical comedians such as Charlie
Chaplin and Rowan Atkinson who plays Mr
Bean of course Thornton also based his
performance on some of the greatest
horror actors of all time like Robert
Englund who played Freddy Krueger and
Kane Hodder who portrayed Jason Voorhees
all of these many influences perfectly
came together to create a truly killer
clown
[Music]